I leave in are you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you claim give
us time and made Terminal and gate we
wanna send you off inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared was it fine now
do you mean arise do you need a wine do
you meet ride do you need a ride do you
meet with Karen and Chris welcome to do
you need a ride this is Chris Fairbanks
I'm about to jump in the car with Karen
kill Gareth we are late to pick up Eddie
Pepitone his actually his flight came in
early it's not our fault
hi just doing that and then I'll give
you your my everything is impossible oh
that's my new approach I guess if you
just expect everything to be impossible
you'll never be disappointed right and
they've been doing first of all American
Airlines is no sponsor oh oh do you need
a round oh are you calling him out well
don't worry about to do this corporate
thing it's a little frustrating how
could he be an almost an hour early well
that's the thing you never plan for is
like something great to happen with the
airport right I I guess I mean that's
the worst place on earth it's the
opposite of Disneyland it's everyone
hates going there and we've decided
that's where our podcasts will often be
driving to of course we don't actually
get out and go there but we have to go
there we have to get into it we have to
drive in to all these people and also I
think it creates that tension people
sitting in a podcast studio booth won't
ever have this kind of emotional
dramatic tension that we have every
episode Chris I am legitimately
frustrated negative feelings are surging
through me and I'm glad I can just bring
it to people always there's Eddie hold
on he's called
he's probably mad at hold on hello hello
wait [ __ ] sorry okay
hello yes so I'm here yes our club we
are like eight minutes away
we are already recording or less yeah
you're you're being recorded right now
okay okay I'm sometimes it does we'll
just keep an eye open for you yeah let
try to wave your hat around in the air
and great okay your podcasts at okay
great yeah and definitely be better
better in the car than you are right now
the higher energy I hope I in a ditch I
hope he was patiently waiting if we can
assume he was impatiently waiting that's
a long time to sit there well he's he
was taxing when he called me and I
miraculously just made it up the 101 and
over the 405 in I think twelve minutes
to get to your house that you must have
been driving like a lunatic I did scream
stop breaking at one point everyone in
front of me seem to just be breaking for
no reason then did they react to your
screams no no that was that was only on
me that's the lesson you never learned
in a car like that is that you're just
making your own environment and toxic
yeah and exactly the negativity that I
scream at others I'm only screaming at
myself yeah it's bouncing back but it
does feel good in the moment because
like if you're just if you're going
downhill on the 405 and all the traffic
is going well don't put on your brakes I
think it says everyone's stoned all the
time I think yeah it's because we got
legal I blame that for a lot of I swear
to God making that weird kind of tippy
tappy braking where you're just like
it's for nothing
hey man are you paranoid hey man did you
get some bad
bag of stuff I I know about as much
about weed as a 70s cop you got a bad
strain of the grass you know reefer
kills right I mean while you're driving
if you brake too much someone can hit
you and then they reefer with you have
something to do with you dying but
anyway I have a moustache badge can we
just talk very quickly about hilariously
vacant I was at the end of our our
Cramer podcast I really did I don't know
you should I don't think that you should
get down on yourself never we should
never look back free once awhile like
yours dead my brain will completely shut
down and I will have a look of fear on
my face without I don't remember if you
recall it was like you had seen a ghost
yeah and the road yeah road goes through
probably the worst road goes where else
they gonna hunt get out of here and get
clipped on your bike and you die on a
curbside you better hunt that Street you
better like that shirt you wore because
you're wearing it for eternity it's
really it's such a bad gig of your ghost
haunting a intersection cuz all you can
really do is mess with the lights yeah
and just kind of spook people on a rainy
night yeah yeah hopefully you're in a
nightgown adds like something I guess I
bet the most popular haunt for street
ghosts is to make puddles splash people
then it's lit more like a street goes
prank yeah and it doesn't have the kind
of weight that you want as a ghost and I
guess the ghost doesn't have the ability
to move a puddle in front of a person or
make a car show up so hard to say though
who knows what those ghosts can do
Christmas angels you know we take a left
here okay yeah are you just naming other
things I'm just saying some dead some
apparitions are able to conjure up
puddles in front of a person standing
there with a brand-new jacket that's
happened on yours what you're saying is
it's happening here yes i ravage Street
ghost does not have that
ability they're just lost but they have
died what happened
no one will acknowledge me since my
funeral which I recall
I've known any for a while and as you
can tell by my half apologetic half
doubling down on just right rubbing salt
in the wound which is very much my style
oh yeah Eddy and I even while they're
down there I like it take them all
they're waiting
Eddy and I have that kind of we're real
stalkers I'd say you keep it real I like
to think we keep it real because we both
think it's funny to be getting his mic
ready oh yeah good idea
cuz we are gonna just pick them up I'm
hunched over I have the mic tucked
between my legs like an electronic penis
you know what I enjoy Chris electronic
penises yeah perfect setup knockdown
it's that every time I real issen to
this podcast and really quickly side
barring thank you so much for listening
to this podcast I love you too do we
really like and if we need to ask for
you to more than listen to it and to
rate it on iTunes oh don't be afraid to
rate it on iTunes rating if oh yeah
positive rating would be even better
than a mediocre one or about you
currently hate what you're listening
yeah in which case don't argue that
don't just don't give us a negative
rating I don't know how much how many
podcasts get that I'd prefer your apathy
than your action against Eddie's mic
test it try to scream into it and then
try to whisper into it yeah yeah that's
how it's going to get with Eddie
Pepitone I am going to have to be
adjusting the ones and twos that guy has
some range so I'm gonna be you know when
he gets into it as soon as he mentions
molestation or Barbara that's like
Barbara the other room was one of my
favorite things as soon as he's doing it
kind of impression of a lounge singer
mm-hmm I'm gonna keep I'm gonna have to
be on them because I know he'll be low
and then he's gonna have a Nam flashback
you're gonna be sliding those levels
around like a regular fill-in-the-blank
of a person who's a famous music and
have you been hanging out with DJs where
did you learn all that specific jargon
I know nouns I had know many specialized
nouns I know many specimens of nouns I
Bragg's
I've Bragg's all day long and by the way
at the end of the last podcast you
didn't shut down I was on a RIF session
with someone that and it was all inside
jokes what are you gonna be are you I
was there to you guys I was in Austin
between the years of 1998 and 2000 you
know there's something about Howard
Kramer though he's a special spirit he
affects me in a different way I think
it's a it's not romantic um well I think
no it's not I mean I know as a jaded you
love it only because I absolutely love
him but it's I think Howard he's one of
the and you would fit into this category
too of like a comedian who's also manly
like actually do dish and manly yeah you
related me to it now I'm starting high
school feeling to it that I really like
me he's very funny but also a chiseled
kind of a physical specimen so yeah it
is hard to podcast for those times it's
hard you know why because most of the
time I'm like this rabid raccoon that's
just trying to out rip everybody but
sometimes I want to be a pretty girl I
would like to be a pretty girl sometime
he has rabies but it's not gonna bite
you he's just gonna try he's gonna
[ __ ] try to beat your joke it is so
unattractive what's this a bunch of
garbage in a trash can
yeah get more like that's what you are
Romney's family
yeah
about garbage in the trash can were the
riffing raccoon is doing political [ __ ]
the record has lost his way
he started out so legit just garbage
stuff and like nighttime stuff raccoon
stuff yes washing his hands person I
can't how come no one's addressing
people talk about monkeys all day no one
is addressing the fact that raccoons
have thumbs
I've seen their little tiny black hands
I've seen them scoop and run with cat
food yeah one of the best video it's the
best video the best also have you seen
the reckon the picture the raccoon
holding the kitten
oh man is up on his legs holding a
kitten like a babysitter it's the cutest
thing I don't know what's he about to
bite it in half cause raccoons and cats
don't mix we don't know we just don't
know maybe but yeah you that was a great
already though this is our best episode
and we don't even have a guest in the
case we're on firing on all cylinders
and I'm not and I'm trying that's before
I even bring up the engine which is
firing on all cylinders but doesn't have
a housing in the oil pan please remember
right there is risk involved that we
have some tension that we're taking on
stage with us exactly and we're now very
close to LAX we're so close that we are
late but we are so close and we're not
late Eddie was early which is that right
rotating we need to keep I'd remember I
said it I predicted it you did predict
it on the bike you see it is creepy I'm
like I have a feeling about this yeah I
have a but I trying to think of someone
on a famous example of superstition but
anyway just any super like like like
don't black cat crossing your path yeah
I have a real Michael to show up early
cuz this is like stepping on a crack and
your mom's back right right right
don't put your hat on the bed that's one
of my favorites yeah don't worry you're
out of the bed right right when Eddie
gets in and takes off the hat that he
will be wearing absolute say hey don't
put that on the bed please don't put it
on the bed and there is a sheet on the
back seat to cover the dog here they'll
just be revealing that you'd sometimes
sleep in your color
I mean the backseat of my car sometimes
I like to go just to parked on a
different city street it may or may not
be in front of Howard Kramer's house
that's all this is not true that's all
we don't have feelings for that sake of
joking she's not really attracted to
Howard she's just acknowledged I mean I
might be attracted to but I don't have
feeling he we can tell he's handsome I
just said we I guess I am too you're
attracted to him or you're handsome too
well during the podcast I felt
intimidated because I'm attracted to his
his present it's like a guy being
attracted to I want to be like this guy
in these ways and sorry I'm let's get
naked I wish that I might you know and
we started making fun of our own podcast
I know yours has a format and you know
that's so unattractive and yeah just no
power moves you know why because Howard
is an alpha that's what it is it is
alpha all the way yeah so you find
yourself you know what I mean I might as
well have like been standing pigeon-toed
like looking down at the ground right so
not me but like it's just the effect a
true not a lot of Chi and that's not to
say he's mean to freshmen high school
freshmen I think he would be it would
mean he would he'd make oh and we're
gonna get right in here yep right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that I'm in oh
you've done it all the time entering lis
she's done it about a thousand times but
I had to tell her and it's American
which is eternal for this is that on the
other side yeah it is indeed is that is
that him again I don't know this is you
hello hold on hold on hold on oh no you
should all stay on this side yeah stay
by the terminal side we are we just
we're just making the loop right now
yes we're moments away from here yeah
yeah yes okay yes yes we'll be there
within
three minutes five minutes okay amazing
that's I just figured out how we should
be recording our podcast I stand at the
airport terminal you put me on
speakerphone it just sounded so great
he's so real well it's I hopefully he's
he's tired I imagine he's very tired but
the question he was asking is kind of
hilarious because he was basically
saying should I go stand where all the
people that are trying to take a super
shuttle yeah yeah no that would be bad
he's like and then we would just stop in
the road I guess we could pull it off
but people would yell at us yeah that
could be good they here at Elliott cut
it washes over me right when I enter
this [ __ ] I really don't like being
here and it's part of my job it's okay
you're right breathe there's some nice
the nose or out the nose through the
nose out the mouth in blue out red in
blue out red and we're coming up on
shuttle I feel better
yeah no it's gonna be fine what are you
doing squirrely just because you have a
lime green car doesn't mean we're gonna
see you in our peripheral what was that
loud Barry laughs I hope that wasn't
gunfire terminal four will be on the
other side I'm afraid we have to cut
past but we don't do that cut through
because that would be Ben no no that
would be bad I think we actually have to
do this loop and go past International
which you know I don't like it sucks
it's Europeans it's kind of stopped
gonna be able to Libyans oh where
there's gonna be so many man sandals and
high-waisted shorts
why is everyone stopped this makes us a
liar about three minutes it's okay it's
gonna be more like four or five comback
wait what the three minutes pass okay
before we warned him no saya tea is such
a fascinating thing look at this guy
what oh just be sideways Oh
Marc at LAX phone number 188 nine one
zero seven 275 has someone's about to
find out how their driving was it was
not good it was bad I didn't like it I
guess that that
was a phone number for actually or we
just advertised for them
that wasn't a phone number you know what
park at park at shuttle at LAX when you
want your shuttle as sideways as all
hell and stopped in traffic it's like
Dickens oh I just wish Eddie could see
how close we were I wish he could see
how great his episode was that we spent
the whole time talking about Howard oh
well well well
what's the opposite of an Alfa what am i
uh an Omega I Omega is that is that it
you're the Omega Man am i a sigma pi uh
Captain cappuccino well you're you're
not you're very LTE you like a good fist
fight oh sorry what time do you want a
moment no it's just that right over a
long time ago it's like what's the most
you know high strung for fraternity it's
kappa kappa chino did you do that on
stage no no it was fourth or fifth grade
yeah there was there early montana
comedy early montana comedy before there
was a stage before I knew what I was
doing unlike today professional nail
that's me Oh nightly I pound that [ __ ]
out we are talking about comedy always
that's not the ladies which I also
occasionally you not afraid to pound a
lady Chris sounds violent wait there are
other things we could tell our listeners
to like do or Olav that do you need a
ride fam tweet your jitter if you're on
twitter and you like it and yeah and I
believe there's a Facebook page as well
there is a Facebook page you're not a
Facebook er I don't Facebook that's okay
not everyone needs to know I know
I feel like less is more on Facebook
yeah thoughts and prayers on Facebook I
just I dunno I get a lot of local gigs
in town on Facebook do I beat yes for
booking a majority of them I can
barely show up to the shows I agree to
do I don't need more well I agree to
them on Facebook and Facebook has
nothing to do with whether or not I show
up that's on me
okay that's on me and my Honda Accord
Honda I need a ride do you do you need a
ride do you need a ride that was that
was good okay Tom I need comma right
question mark do capital do why are all
these people ruining everything you're
really messing up our episode but we're
so close I can see American Airlines
Island oh yeah
Oh Eddie you just have to get in there
Oh Eddie
how do I do it I'm gonna have to get you
I'm gonna have to get old-school New
York cab driver yeah I mean this guy's
doing it there's a cab driver right here
getting new-school
la you get old-school New York on them
we're gonna do an East Coast West Coast
rivalry someone will be shot yeah hey
how about Suge Knight running over some
people this is the new oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't need mean to go topical I messed
up or what that was uh that I thought
that was an old news issue cuz hasn't he
always been he's been killing for a
while yeah yeah he didn't have something
to do with the last time I got in
trouble that's the biggie Tupac thing I
don't know who was killed in from the
automotive museum sorry no memorize
deaths I focus on positive things oh
wait let's get in there oh yeah Brett
remember aggression Olly yes I respect
you York I like it
damn it why is that now Dee it needs to
be in any oh we're we're getting in
there you dork that's right oh okay
let's see here I do not recognize any of
these said l11 something oh yeah we
shouldn't listen to that is this a
Orthodox Eddie standing here with the
huge it is there he is there he is I'm
gonna wave at him no I meant that guy
yeah yeah yeah hey hop on in
oh he needs help okay I can unplug we
can't help you yeah or or do you need to
go in the back back I'm all I'm shouting
very loudly I'm for my recording studio
in my lap sorry oh okay good enough room
here you go Eddie
hey everybody what a day it's a great
day to be
in an airport ah it's really it's they
arranges traffic
we like to try to but if you're you know
what if you're uncomfortable right than
that wouldn't I can kick up this AC for
you yeah a little AC okay
we we're so sorry that we're late but
the only moment right is your flight
right oh it was early and I got a couple
coats so funny that I when I get when I
we taping we are indeed when I got off
the plane it was so [ __ ] movie first
of all I did two shows last night in
Toronto
and I had to be at the airport at about
4:00 for a 6:00 a.m. flight so I did not
sleep I didn't sleep yes ride why even
try yeah I did try but I didn't need
anything but like a couple of you know I
was trying to be good I had like little
trail mix you know of little cranberries
or very good you know the little dried
cranberries everybody loves them I think
I'd like to be the spokesperson for
dried cranberries wake her out the way
Colbert is refer them to carobs what
would that sound like yeah for dried
cranberries commercial it would ran
Berry's a commercial dried cranberries
for dry cranberries yes you know you
know traveling is difficult very
difficult and there's a lot of
temptation to eat salty fatty heart
clogging foods drivers take too many
take to Eddie first of all we want it to
be a little uppity we want it to be up
not like you know it's a TEDTalk so here
we go again with dried cranberries try
and speak quickly
dried cranberries they make travel
better eat them do it now I'm the bitter
Buddha do it
take three
hey are you traveling and going nuts I
know I like Yeti I can't eat half of
this stuff but dried cranberries went
put in with regular nuts make them
sweeter don't they they sure do and
travel goes a lot faster at least the
first half hour ah the second six hours
not so fast but try dried cranberries do
it brought to you to the council for
people who would like to ride
cranberries what I originally was saying
is that you know I've been trying to eat
vegan and I've been well but what but I
lose my [ __ ] on these flights as soon as
I got off this flight I went and got a
whole pizza while I was waiting for you
guys like one of those little boxes and
I ate about four slices that I with the
diet coke and then I had a chocolate
croissant and that and then I have a
coffee and I'm like I feel a lot better
cranberries aren't gonna help you know
red berries don't do it when you're like
ravenously insanely hungry yeah you've
had an entire day of flying that dried
cranberries it's delicious and
convenient as they are for travel are
not going to sustain your energy levels
no that's since I don't know you may got
an argument from the cranberry bog
people who I understand are Hardy and
angry you know what I'll take them on
any day you know they're commercial for
their stupid juice or a farmer's so
things they already did they stole it
from Bartles and Jaymes by the way yeah
isn't it funny how these do you know
these monolithic corporations they get
bigger and bigger and yet they're front
men are too horrific actors you know
from Van Nuys pretending to be farmers
there are no most farmers anymore
there's just machines that eat people
and Monsanto seeds
you have seed 1/2 person that's this
planting things I I think in the near
future because of Monsanto you know with
the GMOs and stuff I think pretty soon
you're just gonna get a knock on your
door it's gonna be like a [ __ ] piece
of corn with a gun the corn doesn't know
the corn dies you you feel they're gonna
modify it to the point where it has
feelings and computers everybody's
worried about the computers taking over
the world
I really think food it's gonna be like
because your idea just crack it open
Pixar do that would they could could
they do it they could one day oh I can't
get the idea of a giant corn with a
little husk grabbing and then it kind of
turns to a hand and they pick up a
firearm yes I don't I think it would be
I think would be easy to do the
characters like like the bad corn is
sort of sort of like bad Sopranos guys
and mafia guys Frankie
and then there's oh and then there's the
renegade corn maybe the organic corn
that's trying to save the war like
they're the good guys
yeah the organic corn would look like
the Thanksgiving corn abhorrent
cornucopia corn it's just like different
colors because they don't ring colors
woody harrelson yeah I think it should
be a Native American do it boys sure you
know you're right about that I mean does
it get more organic than that I hate to
take it to a you know but white people
kicked them out of this country oh sorry
I didn't mean to take it that far no no
no III
you think we did I mean I every day I
watch a video a recreation of the Trail
of Tears just just you know to get the
day started just to check your
priveledge to kick-start grateful I
think you have to look at other people's
atrocities to be grateful you know
because it's so hard to like you know
I'm a big guy who makes gratitude lists
well once a year I do it but when I make
one it's always like oh I'm so glad I
have sneakers it doesn't really that
doesn't cut it oh I'm glad my elbow is
working right no it's like sometimes I
feel like I'm not achieving the things
in life I need to achieve and that's
when I watch Maury Povich he's still on
the air so doing paternity tests
everything and I'm like I'm doing great
why was I so hard on myself oh look it's
got like just to just be Lou their lives
are just such a mess just the the bottom
dwellers of society the bottom users
perhaps bottom feeders they fell down
there cuz that's where they feed backs
and abs of society yes down there eating
[ __ ] over
how does Povich go home like like any
and and I bet he he fancies himself like
an erudite intellectual like like in his
head that's my job yeah like and then he
goes home to a like a nice Sancerre wine
you know
and Connie Chung right doesn't he still
with her too so I think so they're
making it work still Wow
does she ask about his day I've doubted
you know what the both of them she's a
journalist he tells people whether or
not the baby came from there and their
DNA who's to say which is better their
volcon tonnes of pills it doesn't matter
they're both what there are tons of
pills you read that
no I'm it's completely made up but you
know those are nice both of them Maury
Povich and dad eyes they're like dolls
these dolls unfurl they have to be don't
you think
you think Hollywood well if you call
that Hollywood like takes its toll on
you like to show you do like to show you
do you say oh it's just a job right it's
just a job but if it's a horrific thing
day after day were you're watching the
bottom-dwellers and you're profiting off
them yeah I think it nips away it has to
and I know it did to Jerry Springer
because there's a girl in town Lisa
Gottman she we did laughs rides together
for whatever reason her family was very
close to Jerry Springer oh and he was a
sweet man and he was a smart man right
he used to be a mayor of a tent and then
he's basically doing which is violent
pornography on his talk show oh I think
I am talking about expired television
yeah but everyone remember it's yeah
he's like oh and that's cue the oh
that's where her bra strap comes down
and we pick so later bro and then she
punches oh I call it the momentum of
evil and it ties into the cranberry
commercials no problem yeah we it's not
as simple as people think we aren't just
giving rides you are very much doing us
a service by being on our podcast and we
really appreciate it
oh by the way this is great though
because it saves me about a hundred yeah
right right and I with my last thought
before you came was do they charge yeah
we charge $250 maybe maybe that's I keep
saying we should get a sponsor like
Dollar Shave Club or whatever a lot of
these podcasts have razorblade sponsors
for some reason maybe they consider it a
plan B if they want it I mean I make a
suggestion that if you guys become part
of Ober you could Bank so many episodes
we've you know in one weekly one who
gets in the cab you just thrust a mic to
them not like
have confessions or anything but just
lie you're just saying any anyone off
the street Johnny lunch-pail I stream I
don't want to deal with civilians ever
you know you don't want to do that on
your I think you wouldn't have them in
your studio but you know I have you
wouldn't shoplift you wouldn't steal a
car you know when I'm pushed pirate ship
into a stranger's cars what he's saying
but yeah you're right what you want to
get sponsored by uber it and it would be
a comic that we want to have control
over the guests still but then we just
mentioned a code that you'd punch in or
so right come on over there listening
you know they're lazy
you know they listen to every effort
looking at some interesting billboards
does the chappie billboard look
interesting to you the Jackie O I just
saw the trailer for chappie last night
you saw it yes did it look Caroline I
can't remember one thing about it ha ha
ha fact that it was like a horror movie
that was called chappie and the baby
laughed so hard that's a horrible name
that's well nidal I disagree with you
Chris and I don't mean to do it
on the road but I I feel like I feel
like when you put put like a name that
doesn't signify you know what the horror
I think it has more of an impact it's
like it's like when they use children in
horror movies like Daddy like it's
always a bad something when a child says
can I have a glass of water in horrible
because you know [ __ ] is going wickley
you're right and you go to see chappie
and you're like what a light-hearted
English romp I'm about what it's about a
friend now it's about someone's face
melting yeah
wait no is that the one it's choppy the
one by the guy that did district 9 about
robots oh okay then it looked really
good oh yeah
Oh still looks really good yeah I base
all the movies I go on now on the poster
the billboard I won't see your trailer I
won't read a review it's like if the
poster doesn't hit me right it's like no
that's it I'm usually right but really I
think I know from the trailer I remember
seeing it now isn't that just a ripoff
of short circuit now I don't like to owe
a robot with feelings
orange juice not from concentrate like
he was learning about how the human
works and that's what this movie 5 is
alive and there was the Middle Eastern
guy areas Indian in it I thought he was
so funny and then I see him in another
movie and I realized he's doing a
horrible impression he's totally just a
white guy might numbered babies in life
and then and I think they darkened his
face a little I mean don't I mean rules
there wasn't the internet it was didn't
know that hurt people people's feeling
of well I'll tell you [ __ ] like that
goes on when I used to audition for
commercials I don't anymore but when I
used to edition they were looking for a
bald guy to do some [ __ ] horrible
thing like anal leakage whatever it was
and by the way that was my last audition
I'm serious it was for a thing that
stopped anal leakage I'm not kidding
it's an anal leakage kidding Dave you
remember that [ __ ] I met there was Chris
you do I remember it's ours we're
slowing blocky it's just which kind of
fits what that medication did yes okay
so working this was the last commercial
I ever went into in my that's a good
last one and and I go in and it's so you
Milly like and I'm just doing it because
I'm broke then I'm like my my [ __ ]
commercial agent is this really sweet
woman who's very gung-ho and always
saying look one of these things
I had a couple of commercials it changed
my year
yeah yeah but what's her name changed
her life Courtney the progressive woman
loved a lot of people's lives you know
she rebounded pretty well off a very
very bad
first of all image and drug problem
she's done knows and knows yeah she
first knows was rough yeah this one's
more sloppy like a ski jump quickly the
anals a mess I win I was so humiliated
in the first place but then the
[ __ ] director um I I was
reading the copy wrong for some reason
like I was [ __ ] up one of the words
and he got he got literally like kind of
slammed his hand down during an audition
yeah yeah where he was like god dammit
like now you can imagine it's sort of
like Maury Povich these guys get chipped
away if they what they're doing with
their life like anal leakage and what's
the what's another commercial ya know
like a thing to make your hearts
whatever they do he directed the fryer
the viagra jam-band when their music
session I was like I'm on my way yeah
guys you're just your blues you're doing
the blues okay so it's funny we're
talking about this today cuz it's Super
Bowl Sunday and today's the day where
everybody thinks these commercials are
gonna be so do you guys know this right
on Super Bowl Sunday they have the
[ __ ] commercials that are supposed to
be so great and they turn out to be
already seen some of them the laughs
sneak peek at the puppy who hangs out
with a Clydesdale
Budweiser don't drive drunk someone told
me I should see that one is it that
funny I it's it's adorable it's just it
is not it's no it's like a puppy and
that horse takes a liking to it it can
tell the barn and all these and then a
wolf is trying to kill the puppy and
then all the courses all the Clydesdales
gallop over
they scare away the wolf and right and
that's just Budweiser drink responsibly
and did you hear about GoDaddy do
anything where a puckett puppy gets
shipped and they had to pull the
commercial Oh daddy which is the scumbag
yeah um bad corporation run by a CEO who
does big-game hunting I feel don't I get
the money I think I give them money
before my website and I don't even know
why I think GoDaddy sell their stomping
Russian women right that's it oh yeah
and they always have like you know
chicks and be clean for no [ __ ]
reason but but they had a they had a
Superbowl ad where a puppy finds its way
home and this this elderly woman grabs
and say I'm so glad you're here because
I'm gonna ship you because someone wants
to buy you and all these organizations
I'm glad they did I believe that people
would be stupid enough to see that and
go what's it take one day poke holes in
it just like I did with my spider jars
can you imagine a kid just dead puppy in
a box
somehow the puppy got beheaded GoDaddy
sending you a message
now that would go viral but I'm in the
commercial world what we're trying to
say is the commercial world's a
bloodbath it is it's amazing well I wish
I knew what you said instead of anal
leakage you're like when I got the mad
squirts German words were chosen for a
reason but I can't believe I didn't like
tell the guy to go [ __ ] himself a guy's
regret I regret that I didn't do that I
have said things in commercial and then
I don't get seen by that casting yeah
but there's plenty it down at 200
southla place to go out for them I do
yeah I won't I will
unless they're like Eddie they want you
blah blah blah and if it's a decent
[ __ ] product like if it's Doritos
temperature cuz I'm freezing and I can't
feel my feet this always works me a
little bit there's a big difference
between the front and back of cars as
far as they see yeah yeah unless you
have yeah well it's also dangerous I got
in a horrible wreck in a Honda Fit and I
can't wait for you to buy something more
like a Denali oh yeah I'll be safe and
then also air will shoot out into
passengers now get Karen do you have
doggies I do it oh man - oh but I also
collect dog hair and spread it on the
everywhere I that hairs that is the
embedded kind that doesn't fly around it
will not come off I've gone out it with
like lint roller and high-powered
vacuums it's not moving birds from a
field in your sock that shoot legs yeah
they're like ticks you have captain yeah
oh you have both okay yeah man i guy I
have a menagerie of animals I've become
Dolittle ish I've been you know where I
walk in and I'm like hello Sherman these
are all names that have pets hello
Sherman ellos Charlotte hello Katie ello
Louie it's seven animals I live with do
they ever go hello it feels like it my
friend yeah I got a tip of the hat what
we're describing here is delusions
caused by possible mental illness yes as
animals don't and I no offense I just no
no offense but if your pets are talking
to you I don't know you might want to
see a guy I see a guy yeah just a guy
but I see a guy who's sympathetic to
cats and so it goes nowhere right okay
first your cat for me if he likes me
yeah it's just a doctor you think it's
gonna help you or a therapist it's like
hey I get it
Catman - and then you just high-five I
am a cat man myself I love cats oh you
do you I remember that yeah yeah no dogs
though can I say a thing that I should
have said your dogs
I missed it 15 seconds ago high-five and
then Bob Seger's Katmandu please - text
me your address so that we can I could
put it in my mouth oh right you want to
text it yeah because if you say out loud
people you ate outside your house well
you are ready you will get murdered by
our fans I already have several people
outside my place what are they doing oh
they just they're just like please do
the bed come out and it's just annoying
yeah it's hard to live your life thank
you if you just yeah and then molt and I
will I will read it off of your text
good idea and I will transcribe it into
a map navigation on my phone and then
we'll use the hand signals we've pre
rehearsed right silent hand signals -
it's basically just I point left or
right I'm just well you're ready I'm
sorry no no I was just gonna thank him
at a weird time for being on the pod
that guy has no father about cue that
Everclear song he had kids in the car
and he almost sideswiped a Ford Aerostar
tried to come all the way over
yeah I'm really nice Eddie we're we're a
black dick baby on board you were in I
just came from Toronto what's that an
Ian Atlas gig oh I heard that name when
I was out there but you know I've been
talking to him I'd like to go to Toronto
how was it oh man this place called the
comedy comedy underground right it was
super [ __ ] great okay great like like
they're really really
into it you know what I mean land I'd
like Canadians in general yeah me too I
always had fun to go that broad but it's
positive things okay I love all
Canadians all of them Indians are the
greatest they are the best successor
there yet what is it they're really good
natured goddamn reasonable yeah yeah
they're mellow
I never see him stressed out up there
yeah yeah it's clean well I well I was
in the winter man ID so funny I've been
doing this I've been doing this the last
couple of months I've been going to like
[ __ ] Chicago Rochester New York City
going from brutal snowy I do I like I
like the cold weather especially if the
ban out here yeah I don't know land of
the eternal sunshine no seasons seasons
time passing it's a clarity already nice
it's a super birthday but yeah but when
you're an up there in Canadian they just
they just are relaxed all the time yeah
are they smart I mean like smarter than
your average no one accuses them that's
not why you're there that's not look
this is my theory if you're less
stressed you're smarter yes because
stress you know stress con it just
creates all this [ __ ] that gets in
the way of you thinking yeah deductive
reasoning and things yeah I don't think
it's kind of cool to be smart in Canada
where's here it's like football and like
I'm gonna be on American Idol but like
up there I remember my friend Christine
Gooden in high school she had Canadian
cousins that came to visit
and I was I was totally in love with her
one cousin who was probably like 22 and
he brought a Scientific American with
him I thought that was the most I
couldn't get over it it was like made me
weak in the knees because I've never
seen a guy be like kind of in my on my
own time I'm gonna pursue my scientific
arts on my days off I gotta go to my own
school yes there's nothing like that in
my world up until that point yeah yeah I
don't know what that is it's just it's
nice though and and they're great comedy
fans and it's just and they're really
appreciative because I guess you know
there's smaller places and they don't
get a lot of will they do but not often
I think yeah so they're appreciative
appreciative yeah it's not my commercial
editions we go so they're appreciative
right word appreciative because I think
that's what's on the paper so it's anal
leakage you know Eddie isn't that what
it is this potato chip is supposed to
stop no it's that's funny you said
potato chip it was a bite I experienced
an oily kitchen it was from Moline yes
oh well that they would use that that is
what this product was all about yeah
this is like hey do you still like
eating potato chips with I think it was
manufactured Muncie do you go I will
this spot no no but I know he lived it I
head he announced the time to tell you I
was the director ha ha I was wearing
glasses and a scarf so you don't
recognize me and I'm sorry I got mad at
you that let me have a real apology
here's what he did he came in he's like
I'm a I'm a man with a family if when
you get the squirts and I said the
squirts who is this guy we need to
breathe the board it's on the board well
I'm sorry I'm from an improv troupe
holding as we speak well I'm no ending
you because I'm the
factor I said no ending do you got that
address Oh another 101 South right yeah
yeah another another thing I hated about
those [ __ ] commercials was that they
were always directed by Brits and these
horrible [ __ ] spots and and and they
were and and this guy this were these
British guys were those be like alright
if you could just kind of look away when
she says camcorder and like like he had
this to me you had this like [ __ ]
attitude like we're doing this like
amazing dress this is a great round I
love this and you've been you've been
vexed by commercial auditions for so
long because the first time I ever saw
you it's a fake gallery you did that
thing where it was the commercial
attrition with the apocalypse after the
apostles and at the end of that one I
said that at the end of that one it was
only like me like I would say things to
the casting person like it's just good
like they would be like a disembodied
voice and I'd be I'd be yelling David
maybe saying can you read the copy and
I'd be like it's just good to hear
another voice hey you know after this
audition a couple of us are gonna forage
for food if you want to come and then
the casting person answered well that
sounds like just leave a flyer for that
maybe I'll come to that and then at the
end they decided to go with the charred
corpse instead of me to sell cereal
definitely not you it's not you it's
just a different direction thank you
Karen but you know I you know everybody
used to tell me which I also found
insulting Eddie you just you so look
like the everyman thank you thank you
that's not at all inside there your your
insults are so well worth it yeah you
look like the plumber and you're gonna
work and then you're gonna work some
more but mostly plumbing mostly you're a
plumber now I'll never forget going in
one time
for a [ __ ] mucinex Camaro and just
that's the thing we have to sit and go
did book that about three years running
but no of course I didn't invite
everybody fun to be the voice of the
actual book my slightly my stuff I
packed all my book of clothing that I'm
your sickly good oh you're doing it
perfectly but also also like what's
really depressing is like what the
industry saw me as like when I would
walk into the room and see the people
that I was their type it just would
always have to like read a self-help
book after yeah like that oh yeah
because it was like really this is what
I am to you [ __ ] people
if whatever around Christmastime it's
fun to go on them where they ask for a
Santa Claus and every guy in town who
professionally is Santa Claus
to commit it to where they have a big
white beard they maintain a jolliness
they're like well like I lose weight I'm
probably gonna not get as many gigs be
it in a you know shopping mall or on a
commercial or actually it just reeks of
desperation sitting a Children's
Hospital yeah nothing's more desperate
than visiting sick kids that I you said
it kids although that's Isaac sick kids
for myself just so I'm grateful that's
you're visiting sick kids is your Maury
Povich remembering I went on it I only
went on like three commercial auditions
because I was so yeah I was such a
terrible auditioner anyway but all those
ones they would make you improv stuff
yeah yeah and so I was always like out
of my mind I'm comfortable just the
second I got there right and one time I
was waiting in the waiting room and two
dudes who worked at the casting office
got into a fistfight and I got up and
left so quickly and called my agent I
was like two dudes got into a fistfight
I'm not going back there and it was like
they were like my agent called it was
like my client was very upset but I
actually was and I just it was the
perfect excuse oh oh they got into a
fight I'm not going I'm not doing this
ever again you never know I would always
be afraid that my agent I swear to god
it's like just me being a little kid I
would oh wait no keep going okay I would
always be afraid of my agent getting a
bad report it would be like by T's
calling I I worry about it I worry about
the other day I went in for one and yeah
I'm supposed to be a mean director guy
actually are you having fun with them
now like you're going in I like the I'm
getting you starting and I feel like are
you booking any that's cool when what's
Canadian one was in the UK what you know
you wouldn't see oh yeah that's even
better nobody sees you to him exactly I
was pretty happy about that but I want
to go be flown to Japan and do those few
million dollar ones but nobody knows I
got to go to Spain yeah shoot went on
the beach in Spain and then I got to go
to England for a commercial yeah and
what would the product on you say anyone
oh yeah for expediency I am Canadian and
then for a mini coop that's cool when
you could go to Spain Yeah right so I
think I got spoiled and I'm like this is
the best gig ever I'm gonna focus on
this but I
I haven't booked anything right now and
like you mentioned before I've been for
how long food yeah for how long since I
shaved my moustache I haven't had a good
audition when was that
eight months ago okay yeah yeah it is
streaky like that though right yeah yeah
it sounds yeah well it's Marlon is first
ministry getting lucky I think I was
getting callbacks all the time I'm like
well yeah I'm in the groove and we're
sure this groove isn't gonna go anywhere
but straight to the Emperor's got a
brand new anyway it'll make I'm I don't
feel wildly uncomfortable anymore when I
go into a room yeah you know next exit
by the way yes little one on the right
you don't know where it is folks
listening yes because I already have
people in front of my goddamn house
constantly like oh please sign this will
you study the Oh lien bag and then
there's that one guy with the dodgy
hates [ __ ] and which doesn't make sense
see there I always want to go in in
front of a grocery store with a God
hates [ __ ] with what God hates bags
tonight I just look pretty great yeah
pubs I'm tired of working for this here
we go we're taking this you so relax
Teddy because you you're home now
you guys really Wow oh dude did you have
fun I did are you currently having fun
it's not oh yeah I did I'm glad I uh are
you ready for some more fun some of our
episodes I'll be honest or kind of
stinkers this one Aaron Foley and she
was great but I don't want to talk about
her let's talk about you yeah is it n
when you dropped me off or what do we do
ends abruptly and awkwardly and we
actually that's actually kind of cool
yeah and with you stop right here
no just wanted it n the whole time I say
well I came out the other day stop right
here the podcast ends when the podcast
ends we are really close though by the
way why were you very very cool well
then what did your parents say when you
told him that when I came out yeah well
I did come out and the biggest thing I
ever came out as was an actor I told my
dad no when I told my dad I was going my
dad was like a Dean of high school he
wanted and he he kind of wanted me to be
alright how about a dentist I said that
just a pleaser and he was really excited
that I was studying dentistry studied it
that's the same pressure as the elfin
Rudolf he felt he wanted to be a dentist
yeah but he was an elf he was actually
pulled the elfin roof off he was
passionate about dentistry right it's
like why am i amiss why look at me
making these toys I'm like that's a
pretty good gig that's right yeah my dad
gave me a [ __ ] novocaine needle for
my 16th really I'm not kidding it was a
bee
like like state of the yard like you
don't get the scene because they always
hide out now they did that then fight
light a fire under your ass
it sure did when you get a novocaine
needle I'm sorry son I that was supposed
to be covered I put a wine cork on the
end of it you'll probably for a couple
guys used it don't ride your bike behind
my work there's a couple guys in an
alley that I let use the needle but
other than that it's brand new zone and
I want you to be a dentist
what did your dad ever see right behind
this grey car okay no one's gonna bother
a little bit so did your dad ultimately
see you act and realized that you made a
life for yourself or do you know we took
him so long because he heard about the
Olin commercial he heard he heard about
a lot of this stuff because he had a
friend in the commercial industry yeah
that would be funny if like Bob I don't
know he screwed up a couple of words
perfect for him because he he looks like
[ __ ] you know he looks like [ __ ] he's
gonna go far just harness this everyman
which basically means you know a person
who doesn't look well during every man
if everyone in America was a sick
plumber compliment go Eddie you're great
this was fun and night yeah this was
good you are a delight we're gonna go
back to the airport and pick up her nest
yes I know
airports are the one place I hate going
I know they're regularly yeah do you now
kind of dig it I love it
kind of my character I guess but I don't
like I get I get a feeling of anxiety
the moment they know you do some of the
cops know you at this point
that's the podcast let them throw they
notice that there's occasionally a car
where people inexplicably have
microphones in their hands yeah so
you're going to get I just realized that
we might be suspects since we're at the
airport so much checking out that lady
oh yeah we could be we could be in
serious danger but no look around it
whatever you feel like looking I wanted
to warn her that'll cause permanent
hanging all right guys thank you so much
you have a podcast do you want to talk
about that yes um please listen to my
podcast on the all things comedy network
what's called pep talks with the bitter
Buddha and you could subscribe to it on
iTunes I'm gonna be at the San Francisco
sketch fest Oh fun coming up February 6
7 & 8 okay that's it green rabble fest
and I with the end of February and then
the punchline March like 11:00 I'm gonna
headline a punch oh that's great great
yeah nice that's to San Francisco trips
or is it right that's right it's it's
San Francisco I wa and then back to San
Francisco to go get your heart go back a
second time to get your hurry everyone's
leaving their heart there right thanks
for being on do you need a ride Dyn AR
either way we wanna be here doesn't
matter how much baggage you give us time
and a terminal engage
we want to send you love inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared or was it fine now horn
do you mean right do you need a ride do
you need a mine
do you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need with Karen and Chris
you